welcome to all to this conversation with
dr francis collins francis collins as i
think many of you know is a physician
geneticist noted for his landmark
discoveries
of disease genes and his previous
leadership of the international human
genome project which culminated with the
completion
of a finished sequence of the human dna
instruction book dr collins currently
serves
as a senior investigator in the
intramural program of the national human
genome research institute pursuing
genomics research on type 2 diabetes and
a rare disorder of premature aging
called progeria
dr collins was appointed by president
barack obama as the 16th director of the
national institutes of health
where he oversaw the work of the world's
largest supporter of biomedical research
his tenure spanned an unprecedented
three presidential administrations dr
collins was awarded the presidential
medal of freedom in november of 2007
and received the national medal of
science in 2009 in 2020 he was elected
as a foreign member of the royal society
in the uk and was also named the 50th
winner
of the templeton prize and with that
please welcome dr francis collins
hi francis how are you
good brian how you doing it's been a
while it has been a while it's great to
see you and uh thanks for joining us in
this conversation
and and just to give a sense
are you in dc are you in washington dc
at the moment
i'm just outside i'm in chevy chase
maryland in my home office uh joining
you here on a saturday night but hello
to brisbane hello to australia glad to
be part of your part of the world
science festival
even as we all hope that someday before
too much longer we'll actually be able
to be together in person
yeah that would be fantastic we also
have people joining us since this is you
know online we've got people joining us
i had a list of countries just a moment
ago flashed up
india north carolina which isn't quite a
country calgary i'm going to start a
pakistan oregon you might
we'll leave that we'll leave that debate
for later on but um i wanted to begin
with just
giving the audience a sense of of your
background which
um it was a little bit unusual i i read
once that you described
your parents as quote doing the 60s
thing but prematurely i think it was
they did in the 1940s so so what exactly
did that mean for a youngster such as
yourself growing up
um yeah it was a very unusual way to get
started by the way brian i should say i
am also now
asked by the president of the united
states to be his acting science advisor
so i have a new job
yeah so congratulations on that
yeah and thank you and so i must must
declare here at the beginning of all
this i am speaking
from my personal perspective and not as
a representative the u.s government in
case anybody wanted okay um so yeah i
grew up on a small farm uh about three
hours from here in the shenandoah valley
of virginia a beautiful part of the
country
my dad was a folk song collector who had
done a lot of things with musicology in
in the previous decades and a lot of his
collected songs are in the library of
congress
and yet after the war he and my mom
moved to this farm 95 acres with no
indoor plumbing
and raised four boys of which i'm the
youngest
and also started a summer theater in a
grove of oak trees up above our
farmhouse which i'm glad to say uh has
been in continuous operation
uh despite covet for more than 60 years
wow it's become quite a wonderful way
for the communities in the shenandoah
valley to get together so i was raised
surrounded by interesting people who
wanted to talk about shakespeare or
philosophy or music especially music my
dad was a classical violinist who became
a fiddle player after spending some time
in west virginia working for eleanor
roosevelt
so it was a very eclectic kind of way to
grow up and my mom taught all four of us
brothers at home
until she got tired of it and not
because she had any religious interest
at all she did not but because she
thought she was a better teacher than
the public schools and i think she was
right so brian i had this amazing
experience of figuring out that learning
was fun because that's what my mother
made it to be
yeah i mean
plans everything was a little chaotic
like what's interesting today let's
study that i mean that's the way to do
it i mean
i try to get that idea across to my kids
and i think i'm not all that successful
at doing it i mean it's hard for kids to
really see
learning in that life but maybe if you
if you haven't gone to school initially
maybe it's just as part of life maybe
that's the secret you know you know and
that's the way it was for me she was
very gifted we would study mathematics
uh sometimes for several days on end
just mathematics because it was
interesting and then kind of hit a wall
and like okay i'm frustrated let's do
something else okay let's study history
here let's read charles dickens and see
what we can learn about literature or
you know let's let's really see what we
could learn about the weather
right he was capable of bringing all of
those things to the table
in a way that made it seem like fun and
you never felt like oh this is a drill
and i've got to learn something just
because somebody told me to it's like
i'm curious because she's helping me
become curious and i carry that with me
today
yeah that that that that's the ideal way
you know a few years ago by the way i
don't even know it was a few years any
longer because my sense of tommy i think
like everybody else's is completely off
because the last couple years but you
and i were on a bus we must have been at
some conference together i cannot
remember what it was but you were a few
rows in front of me on this bus filled
with scientists and i was sort of half
asleep but then i started hearing you
talking about
quantum mechanics and wave functions and
like my ears couldn't help but perk up i
was not trying to listen in on your
conversation but somewhere in your
education you got driven toward science
and and and i gather you spent quite a
lot of time learning about physics and
physical chemistry and and so forth when
did that happen
well i did end up going to public school
a little later on my mom kind of reached
the end of a rope here with these four
boys
and we moved in town where the public
schools were actually pretty good and
and i'm i can't say enough about how a
really good public school can inspire uh
kids about science it was a 10th grade
chemistry teacher john house that got me
to see that science was something i want
to spend my life on this is like so
exciting so interesting it's like a
detective story you have these tools and
you can figure out how nature works and
why wouldn't you want to put yourself
into that absolutely completely and i
love math so i went off to the
university of virginia i majored in
chemistry but the part of chemistry i
liked the most was the part that was
closest to math so it was physical
chemistry it was really physics
and went on to get a phd at yale in what
was called physical chemistry but most
of my courses were in the physics
department and my
my phd dissertation was semi-classical
theory of vibrationally inelastic
scattering so there you go it was all
done with some pencil and paper and a
lot of boxes of fortran cards running up
and down the hill onto the yale computer
center to try to see if i could
calculate collisions between protons and
hydrogen gas and come up with something
that looked like a reasonable outcome
solely based on quantum theory
yeah yeah you know i i am definitely old
enough
when i was a kid i was doing all my
computer program with stacks of pork
tran cards i'd be running down to nyu
on saturday mornings then you get one
card wrong you have to wait another hour
to run
you know it's kind of crazy back then um
so so ultimately after that phd
you of course shifted more toward the
biological sciences and we're going to
get to your profoundly important work on
the human genome project in just a
moment but i did want to spend a little
bit of time
on because i think it gives really good
context for the work that you do and the
motivation with the work you do i want
to spend time on the fact that you're
not just a revered scientist you are
also
a devout believer you know in a higher
power in god is it okay if we spend a
little time talking about
yeah so
so you know richard dawkins
you know
emphasizes repeatedly that
many adults who hold to a religious
belief got it from their parents that
it's sort of a it's passed down
generation generation that certainly is
not the case with you right
no not the case at all my parents late
in life
uh became
sort of believers my dad more than my
mother but they certainly were not that
way when i was growing up
yeah and and so
what what was your journey then i mean
was it at a very young age you had some
experience or was it somewhat later on
i mean i did have experiences i bet
almost everybody does some of those
moments where they feel like there's
something
something significant some longing that
you have for something bigger than what
you can quite put into words
maybe it was a particular beautiful
piece of music because i loved music
from the time i got started and i found
moments where listening to a particular
symphony i would be totally caught up in
that even to the point of tears and
wondering what is that all about
so beauty maybe as a signal of some sort
but also i just felt
while i was
focused completely on physics and
chemistry and i loved every bit of that
when i got to medical school which is
what came after my phd training
i felt there was something missing here
especially as i sat at the bedside of
good north carolina people who were
dying and
who
were able through their faith to make
some sense out of it and i couldn't and
i thought of myself in their position
and i thought i just i have no idea what
they're talking about
when these people are saying i'm going
to be okay because i put my trust in
jesus and i was like what is that all
about
and one afternoon one of my patients who
i had gotten up probably closer to than
you're supposed to as a medical student
a grandmother leak sort of character
asked me point blank what i believed
because she told me what she believed
and i realized i had absolutely no idea
at that point i would have said i'm an
atheist but i also realized i've arrived
at that position without really doing
any work at all
to try to sort through the options and
figure out why i've chosen that one
other than it's the one i kind of liked
because i didn't like the idea that i
had to be responsible to anybody other
than me
yeah
and and and so
in a sense it was
your scientific orientation that drove
it in a sense right you're basically
saying i haven't interrogated this
sufficiently to have a position
exactly and as a scientist which i claim
to be at that point you're not supposed
to make really important decisions
without looking at the evidence and i
had to say to myself you didn't do that
so okay better get busy boy and i
assumed brian that what i would then do
would be to look at the pros and cons of
her belief and i would be very effective
in strengthening my atheism
and to my surprise it went the other way
it took two years this was not a simple
like you know uh all-nighter where you
kind of study what people believe about
god and then it's all clear and let me
be clear there's no proof of god's
existence that i found but i certainly
found
intriguing evidence and some of it
within my own heart
that ultimately forced me to say atheism
just won't do for me it's the denial of
something it's a universal negative
claim which scientists in general are
supposed to avoid
and even within science itself i saw
things that i couldn't explain
without some idea of a creator that set
the universe in motion there was a big
bang it all started somehow okay that's
hard to understand
the fine-tuning of the universe which
you know very well where all of these
constants that determine the behavior of
matter and energy
seem to have been set in a precise area
where even a tiny tweak would make the
whole thing just really not interesting
at all without any possibility of
complexity
that was a doozy for me the so-called
anthropic principle
we could talk about multiverses and that
has to be the alternative there but that
also seemed to require a huge leap of
faith and maybe still does
so
little by little bit by bit and maybe
again reflecting back on those moments
as a child and a young adult of that
glimpse of something that you just
longed to understand long to experience
and couldn't quite put your finger on
and then ultimately for me
this question of morality and where does
it come from and if you're going to be a
strict evolutionist and i've had this
argument with richard dawkins as
recently as a month ago and it'll be up
in a podcast pretty soon if you're going
to be a strict evolutionist you almost
have to come to the conclusion that good
and evil don't really have any
fundamental bases
they're kind of in there as something
evolution has convinced us matter for
our survival but they don't really have
any substance and that's a really hard
one to swallow i could not swallow that
and if there's a source of morality that
can't be explained on natural grounds
and if there's evidence for a creator
based on all of these other insights
well then maybe the creator is also the
source of good and evil and that means
that's a god who cares about people so
not to necessarily recapitulate or step
on the podcast of yours and riches
that's coming up and i i don't know
anything of it beyond your mention of it
just now
it's interesting that you mentioned
those two examples sort of the big bang
is a mystery morality
as a mystery i wouldn't mind spending a
moment talking about each of those
because i find it interesting
that you don't
look at
the emergence of life
as a mystery that rises to the level
that would need to invoke a creator
and i suspect and correct me if i'm
wrong it's because
you understand it well enough like we
still haven't be able to create life in
the laboratory but i think we understand
the chemistry and the biology and the
basic ideas well enough that we can see
the trajectory that'll take us from here
to there without intervention of any
non-scientific principles but for the
big bang
you see it in a different category i
gather because it rises to a place where
you want to invoke a creator
could that simply be
a lack of understanding not necessarily
on your part but just on on the part of
science and and this will be remedied at
some point and that argument will kind
of fall the way of many god of the gaps
type arguments yeah that's fair brian
and on the other hand i think if it does
fall by the way we'll still be left with
the question of why is there something
instead of nothing yes
and that's a really hard one to come up
with a scientific answer to
if in fact there is a physical mechanism
that allows out of nothing or
essentially nothing a universe to come
into being
13.55 billion years ago okay that
doesn't tell me to be more in
to be less in awe of the creator but
maybe more in awe of how there is
something instead of nothing what i see
and if you'll accept the premise of
people listening of the idea that there
might be a creator behind this then the
most awesome kind of creator would
instill a within nature within the
universe the potentiality of life right
down to the point of our having this
conversation with full intention that
that kind of blossoming of beauty and
complexity was part of the point
and if god is the creator that put this
all in place then god couldn't very well
be limited in time otherwise you've
created an infinite regress and you have
to explain how god was created so god
has to be outside of time and outside of
space
in which case
the idea of being able to put all of
this sort of pregnant with potential at
the very moment at the beginning of the
universe is even more amazing than if it
required supernatural intervention along
the way as some of the intelligent
design folks seem to claim to be
necessary i am not a fan of intelligent
design but i'm a fan of the creator and
of evolutionary creation
because the data supporting the fact
that we are as living species all really
related to each other through a common
ancestor is overwhelming and i think
that's fantastic that's even more
amazing i i i agree that you know if if
one takes obviously the premise that
there is something beyond
the physical and i guess the worry that
that that i have when i look i'm asked
all the time perhaps you know the second
most frequent question i'm asked is what
happened before the big bang the most
frequent question is what's quantum
entanglement do you understand it but
that's for a different conversation uh
and and so when people ask me what
happened before the big bang
obviously i find myself potentially in
that infinite regress because if i
actually speak of something that itself
could have had a beginning the question
is well where did that come from and so
it feels to me that the religious answer
just redefines the question by invoking
a term god that stands outside by
definition the infinite regress but i
feel like i could use any word to do
that it didn't have to be
a god-like term does does that hold any
issue for you thinking that in that
setting
no i hear what you're saying and you
could invoke any other kind of term but
then you have these other aspects of
what we have within human experience and
i'll come back to morality and whether
it actually has any meaning or not
that compels me to say okay maybe
there's something more here than just an
explanation from physics about how the
universe got started there's something
about what it means to be human that
maybe physics isn't quite answering and
requires some other insight and that's
where i begin to follow
the ideas that many others have put
there long before me
uh that point to something that crea is
not a deist kind of god yeah kind of god
that actually is interested in human
beings
right so that does that doesn't actually
take us to the other
part of the argument the morality
argument
and and here
you know it's interesting so you made
reference to it a moment ago in your
conversation with with richard about
this view that if you take evolutionary
perspective or even a physicalist
materialist perspective
fully to heart
then
good and evil and beauty and wonder and
compassion and empathy and love they
have no grounding
they are are just
qualities that emerge that certain
collections of particles are able to
come up with and some live by it and
some don't
and i have to say that is that is my my
view
and and the thing that that i'm curious
about is
i find it potentially even more
exalting even more spectacular
that
a collection of particles called the
human brain that emerge fully through
evolution by natural selection is fully
governed by the laws of physics the fact
that this highly organized collection of
particles could come up
with ideas of of beauty and wonder and
insight and compassion and ethics we
don't always live by these ideals but
the fact that this gloppy grey thing can
come up with it feels to me even more
exalting than putting those qualities at
the feet of a divine presence who gave
it to us
do you do you see what i'm saying there
i i totally hear you and uh that's very
much what richard would also say having
just had this conversation but doesn't
it bother you a little bit
then that things that we as humans down
through the centuries
have considered fundamental about what
it means to be human particularly the
fact that there is such a thing as good
and we're called to be good and there's
such a thing as evil and we should avoid
that that that might actually be
artificially created by those particles
by evolution and it really means we've
been hoodwinked there's there's nothing
underneath that
that i find that deeply troubling
it's so interesting because i don't find
that the slightest bit troubling and i'm
not doing that to play devil's advocate
or or you know just be a combatant in a
conversation
to me
the universe is just
ingredients governed by the physical
laws that you and i know well from
quantum mechanics and the various
flavors of the laws that have been put
forward in that way
and to me
there is nothing else and so i stand in
awe
of the fact that without anything else
these wondrous things can happen that
can yield beethoven's ninth symphony or
that can yield the mona lisa it can also
yield tragic
qualities of the world and we're
witnessing that today as we sit here
right now but the fact that particles
can
yield such wondrous ideas without
anything else we don't have to
place the burden on something else or
look to something outside of ourselves
for the origin to me
makes these ideas even more
in need of reverence than if they did
come from a religious force
i get that with a lot of the elegance
and complexity of the universe because i
see that as a manifestation of what was
put in place
at the very beginning of creation by
whatever means sure and i i can say that
i admire today's sunset which was
particularly beautiful and that that
touched me in some way at the same time
i know exactly why it is that those
colors appeared as a consequence of the
laws of physics
it's when it comes to good and evil that
i am still troubled by simply dismissing
that as a purely materialistic outcome
of an evolutionary process but i admit
i'm also influenced here by my own
particular faith which does include not
just
some sort of theistic ideas but a very
specific version of faith which i
arrived at kicking and screaming over
two years
uh basically encountering the person of
jesus christ which i found impossible to
dismiss and who claimed not just to be a
wise master and a thoughtful teacher but
actually to be connected as the son of
god and that's an outrageous claim that
could not be accepted without an awful
lot of evidence and yet the evidence is
pretty compelling by those who wrote
about his time here and who um by the
report of eyewitnesses and not just was
on the planet but actually was crucified
and then was resurrected and people look
at me as a scientist and say well you
can't possibly believe that but go with
me a minute if if there is the
possibility of god who cares about
humanity a theist god who wants humanity
somehow to strive for the good and to
reject the evil then why would that god
not also be capable of appearing as a
person on the planet for a time to teach
us a lot of important things and even to
sacrifice in the most brutal imaginable
way
to somehow make up for the price that we
should have paid for all of our
behaviors i found that as a child to be
just bogus crazy what are you talking
about and now i found it to be
incredibly compelling truth so my faith
as
based solely on the kind of conversation
we're having about
nature and morality would be okay
but it gets a lot more specific when it
comes to this particular kind of faith
of christianity and the person of jesus
and and and you know i am not one of
those
scientists or or thinkers who says how
could you hold to that perspective at
all i think it's obvious that one can
hold that perspective if you view
science
as a body
of truth and insight into some qualities
of the world but not every quality of
the world and once you allow for it to
be a just a subset
if they're things that are beyond the
reach of physical law then those
qualities could be radically different
from anything that we're familiar with
or that we've experienced
at the same time what would hold me back
and i'm wondering how you you view it
can you envision
any experience or or any insight from
any source
that would convince you that you're not
right that that jesus is not who you
thought he is or that your faith was
misplaced in your earlier version of
your your younger self who saw it as
bogus was was correct yes absolutely if
there was a credible uh
evidence-based discovery of the bones of
jesus uh somewhere in a crypt
uh in israel uh then my faith would
utterly fall apart it would so you would
not find some other
poetic metaphorical interpretation
the bones are there but the spirit
laughed no i'm sorry it wouldn't it
would no longer be credible i would have
to abandon it absolutely and do you
stand in any kind of fear of that
happening or you just have a
you've you've interrogated the evidence
sufficiently that you feel you're on
solid ground as solid as one can be but
you know faith is not something at least
for me that's associated with absolute
confidence and doubt is a big part of my
faith and i think a big part of most
people's faith
otherwise you're not being totally
honest with yourself
but brian i think the difference between
you and me could be put in sort of a
bayesian calculation
my prior probability of there being a
creator god
is not huge but it's not zero yours is
zero
and if you've stepped into every
situation with that prior of zero you're
going to find some other way to explain
the observations whether it's fine
tuning of the universe or the person of
jesus where for me i came into it after
that medical school experience saying
okay let's allow the prior not to be
zero anymore
let's see what kinds of things fit into
that and to my surprise it took me
somewhere that i found to be deeply
meaningful
right and and just just just for the
record for me the prior if we're talking
bayesian for a second it's not actually
zero so i would say it's small and it's
sufficiently small
that if i do a bayesian like calculation
i still come down on physicalist
materials explanations for for all of
the mysteries that that i've ever
encountered so what would change your
mind you asked me that question what
would cause ryan green to say okay i get
it god you are real and you care about
me
it's a great question it's a very hard
one to answer because
i could throw out ideas and in other
conversations i've flippantly said
things like if the clouds parted and you
know the face came down and said here i
am you know that that would be
convincing but then i said myself would
i really be convinced or would i check
myself in a bellevue hospital and and
think of a more you know so so i don't
have a full
answer to that question but i will say
that i'm open to the possibility whereas
i know that many of my colleagues are
simply not their prior is zero and will
always be zero and we'll never take them
i don't think that sort of dogmatic
stance you know the famous you know the
famous bertrand russell story and that
somebody asked bertrand so suppose you
actually die and you go to heaven and
there's god saying ah you know bertrand
why were you so against me why didn't
you believe in me and russell says sorry
god not enough evidence yeah right
exactly
uh so i think at that point it would be
enough evidence for me to say but but
when it comes to religious texts
obviously some people
watching this conversation will say but
look
there are places where science and
religion
are just at loggerheads they just cannot
blend together now my view on that has
always been if you take a poetic or
metaphorical stance when it comes to
religious texts
then using an interpretive schema you
can make
everything blend together
do you hold to that view and like is
there a place where you draw the line
there must be where you say poetry and
metaphor okay in this part of religion
but not in this part
certainly when i look at the bible it's
important to see what kind of language
is being used here and who is the
audience that this particular book of
the bible was written for a lot of the
trouble seems to arise in genesis 1 and
2 about creation but read john walton
who's an old testament theologian at
wheaton college which is a pretty darn
conservative christian place about what
it was that genesis 1 2 would have meant
to the original readers it was not
intended as a science textbook it was
not even clear that they were talking
about days of creation and the specific
sense of physical days but more of a
metaphor of building a temple it's a
wonderful book and it really helped me
see so many ways in which this over the
course of many centuries has led people
into directions that weren't really
called for i mean you go back to saint
augustine in 400 a.d who was obsessed by
genesis and ultimately said i can't
figure out what is intended here and let
nobody pretend that they know the answer
and then make christians out to look
stupid because they turn out to be
scientifically wrong well here we are
that's kind of happened so i you know i
became a christian at age 27.
i was already deeply interested in
genetics people said your head's going
to explode this is not going to be
compatible it's never happened brian
you know more than 40 years later i've
never seen an instance
where my insistence as a scientist for
the most rigorous evidence if you're
going to tell me something about nature
you better show me what your data looks
like
to conflict with what i know as a person
of faith is just you got to be careful
which question are you asking
and which approach makes sense but i'm
not a fan of the stephen j gould idea of
non-overlapping magisterity that you
have magisteria you have to keep these
somehow
separate with a big firewall they're not
a firewall in my experience in any given
day i wake up i read the bible i do a
scientific
data analysis or read a paper try to
come up with some sort of decision about
a new project it all fits together it's
all part of god's creation
and so but so when it comes to genesis
one and two
metaphor poetry interpretive schema
works well but but you are saying that
when it comes to say just to be concrete
the resurrection is not metaphor it's
not poetry
yes well read read the words and this
does not read like poetry this reads
like history written by eyewitnesses of
events that happened that were dramatic
that were written down with great care
that leave really not much room for you
to say oh that was just somebody's
emotional experience there's some
emotional experience to be sure but it
is written as eyewitness history you
can't discount that and just walk away
from it as if it didn't matter people
have tried i can't seem to do that
and so when it does come to your work
say in genetics if we can turn to that
now
that presumably is something which again
you're saying you don't see a firewall
you don't need a firewall between that
work and religious perspective but
when you go to the lab you're using the
traditional tools approach that that of
course every other scientist is using
when did you start
work in genetics presumably was a good
deal before the the human genome project
it was when i was a graduate student
studying quantum mechanics
that i discovered that i narrowed my
horizons a bit prematurely
by discounting biology because it just
seemed way too messy i bet you would
resonate with that because that was my
attitude now i wonder if like maybe i
should have had a more open mind but
anyway this is your story not mine uh
yeah but you know i was in the
department of chemistry and there were
actually people in that department
studying dna and uh when i heard what
they were doing it perked me up i was
like wow that's really you really that's
how it works i had ignored all of this
and it felt like a real calling if i'm
going to put my life into science i want
to do something that maybe could make a
difference and quantum mechanics could
do that as well but this just seemed to
be so pregnant with possibilities this
was like
1973 recombinant dna was being invented
so that's what lured me away
off to medical school to try to see
could i learn that science and could i
apply it to that and why medical school
as opposed to like like you know
postdoc and biology or something well
that was a hard decision because it
meant a lot more years of training
i will tell you brian i had kind of lost
my own sense of confidence about whether
i was really cut out to be a researcher
sort of recognizing that i've been on
this very narrow perspective i'm going
to be a quantum mechanics expert and
then realizing maybe that's not my
calling anymore what am i going to do so
maybe i should try to kind of keep some
options open here and if i'm not going
to be a researcher maybe i could be a
doctor why that argument got me admitted
to the university of north carolina
medical school could be debated because
it wasn't a very compelling
way to say why i wanted to be a
physician which i'd never really thought
about until i was like 22.
and so you so your research took you to
ultimately
genetic studies of various human
afflictions um what did you focus on in
in the in the earlier part of that work
well i spent eight years learning how to
be a doctor
and i really tried to throw myself into
that and i encountered many instances as
a guy interested in genetics where there
were these really terrible diseases
nobody understood other than to say they
were inherited you didn't really know
why or how or what you should do for
them
so that seemed like something maybe i
could bring together my love of science
and my love of medicine and find some
answers so once i finally got through
all that training and ended up as a
assistant professor at the university of
michigan i focused on trying to find the
genetic glitches that cause diseases
like huntington's disease and cystic
fibrosis
and it was hard back then there was no
genome to just
look up on the internet because there
was no internet and so sifting your way
through uncharted territory which is
most of the genome trying to find what
might be one letter out of three billion
that was misspelled was brutal and many
people thought this is hopeless this is
never going to work and it took many
years and a lot of burned out people
along the way but i learned to
collaborate when you couldn't figure
something out yourself find somebody
else who has a complimentary approach
and the big moment for me where i really
believe this could work was finding the
cystic fibrosis gene in 1989
a discovery which 30 years later has now
led to the fact that most people with
cystic fibrosis 90 of them have a really
effective treatment that's allowing them
not to think about their next
hospitalization but about maybe what
they'll do when they retire
that was a single letter i guess that is
three actually yeah ctt that's deleted
in most people with cystic fibrosis and
a gene that nobody had discovered before
but i also thought at the time okay we
got there but this was incredibly
stressful and painful and took way too
long and cystic fibrosis should have
been one of the easy ones it's
relatively common it's very well
understood in terms of its inheritance
what about the thousands of other
hereditary conditions we've got to have
a better way to do this and that was a
big motivation for the genome project
which i then got very involved in and so
when people i i guess with your
experience trying to find you know
individual letters that that might be
responsible for or this or that disease
when people began to talk about
sequencing the entire human genome
was that something that the field
basically said we'll be able to do this
yes
no yeah yeah no go back and read some of
the commentaries in 1989 and 1990
most of the scientific community was
opposed to the human genome project as
being absolutely foolhardy it'll never
work the technology will never mature to
the point of being able to read that
many letters of the code uh it'll cost
way too much money which will be
siphoned away from more useful things
and by the way this was the most
troubling one only mediocre people will
want to work on it because it's so
boring it's like come on i want to work
on it i don't think i'm a mediocre give
me a break here
and you're all wrong
and and so i guess jim watson
was the initial leader is that is that
my memory correct on that you have that
right and jim as the rock star of
science got the congress of the united
states interested in actually supporting
this which was important
and then by alienating almost everybody
by the fact that jonas not somebody
who's careful about what he says uh
disappeared rather quickly from the
leadership and uh then a new leader had
to be found
we were all terrified about what that
meant and to my surprise it turned out
to be me
and did you immediately jump at that or
did you have your own reservations about
taking i had deep reservations
i was a faculty member at the university
of michigan i was supported by howard
hughes i had this perfect life that i
had hoped for of teaching medical
students which i enjoy
seeing patients and running a research
lab and we were on the trail of all
kinds of interesting
detective stories and this meant what
giving all that up and becoming a
federal employee
to run
a government program
i said no um for the first few months
and then eventually
you know brian you get asked once in
your life to do something that really is
not what you were expecting this door
opens
but it's running the genome project and
you're going to walk away from it
because it's not convenient oh
yeah i mean it's high risk high reward
oh yeah there's a possibility there
if you don't mind my asking
since we just discussed faith earlier on
in facing a decision like that
does faith play a role in your personal
life to figuring out what to do oh yeah
i every time i've had a big decision
i have tried to find a place to be set
aside without distractions
a retreat of some sort
for that decision i spent a
very long day in a little chapel in
chapel hill north carolina where my
daughter was at that point
a uh undergraduate or maybe she was a
medical student by then
just on my knees trying to figure out
what was this a calling or was this
really something that was a distraction
that was not going to turn out well
and at the end of that long day somehow
even song occurred in that chapel which
i hadn't expected
i took part in it and it felt like i
have peace
this is something i should do
and so you you you took the helm of the
human genome project
and i guess it wasn't too long after
that
some competition cropped up
from
from the private sector
uh craig venter and
and and his his approach
and and the question i have for you
there is
was that
competition
driven by
wanting to be first to get this result
or was it i guess the other side of it
was
there was a there was a threat at some
level that the results
could be
patented and kept
from from the public was it a blend of
those two that that drove you on the
competition front
it was more the latter to be honest
craig had been part of the public effort
uh he was funded by the genome project
through the nih for the first few years
and then he stepped aside from that
started this company called solera and
aimed to try to beat the government
effort by getting there first and made
it very clear that he intended uh to
recoup
the investment of his stockholders
by claiming ownership of the dna
sequence our shared inheritance that was
anathema to all of us who worked in the
public project and were giving the
sequence away every 24 hours that was
our goal
and so it very much became not so much a
race about who's got better technology
we're using the same technology
it became a race about whether this is
going to be a commodity or whether this
is going to be in the public domain and
certainly many of us felt very strongly
about that
ultimately i mean he did a credible job
he was using all the public data because
it was public
and adding some of his own to it but the
public data was good enough to generate
a really good version of the human
genome project by the summer of 2000
when there was this announcement that a
draft was in hand and shortly after that
the private sector fold it because there
was no reason for that to continue there
was not going to be a product there that
they could claim it was already out
there in the public domain it was a good
outcome
and so was the competition in your view
and retrospect was it a good thing that
there was competition to sort of
it probably was it got everybody's
adrenaline going
people were working really hard they
worked even harder than to be sure that
this wasn't something that ended up out
of reach for the average member of our
human species
and it got more public attention because
up until the point that there was this
so-called race for the genome most
people didn't even know it was happening
and now all of a sudden oh this guy has
a yacht and that guy rides a motorcycle
and it became people magazine and it got
attention and i
i gather you in the motorcycle
yacht is that
i got the motorcycle yes
and some of it was ridiculous but at
least it got public interest like oh
what is this is this going to make a
difference maybe this is something to
pay attention to and they did
and you you
kind of famously in in describing the
result
blended
your personal faith in terms of a
description i guess you've described the
human genome as as god's instruction
manual for life for some where in that
that combination of work is that how you
do see it i did again not that i saw
that god had sort of reached in here and
written out the ac's g's and t's but as
we talked about earlier that in my view
god the creator
made it possible through the natural
laws that i also think god was behind
god as the greatest physicist the
greatest mathematician for a universe to
come into being that would lead to this
moment where for the first time a big
brain species was able to read their own
instruction book that's pretty
breathtaking
but but you you also do not describe
yourself
as a deist i got you you don't
or maybe in part you do
you know some would say god set
everything up at the get-go receded back
and allowed the laws of physics to cause
the universe to expand
collections of particles to coalesce
into atoms and molecules i mean
ultimately when we talk about the
genetic code
it's four letters three billion letters
long but each of those letters is a
stand-in for a very specific molecule
which is a collection of very specific
atoms held together by very specific
forces you don't think that god's
interceding
in those details is that is that right
no god is much more awesome than that
god put this all in place so that that
would be the inevitable outcome of what
started more than 13 billion years ago
but it's not a theist god who then got
bored and went on to do something else
again coming back to my faith god is
interested in us god cares about good
and evil god actually came to join us
for a few brief years in the person of
jesus that's atheist god if there ever
was one
but why would god
make things
so complicated
i mean as a physicist
the laws of nature i i do see have a
simplicity and elegance of course
but the the richness of the world that
emerges from that
it's a very
complicated process and you could
imagine that if god wanted things to
turn out a particular way there might
have been a simpler approach
does that not suggest to you that
maybe it wasn't that kind of intelligent
designer
behind it all
no i don't see it that way i think what
we see in terms of the incredible
complexity is part of the gift because
complexity also means beauty in many
ways it makes it more interesting sure
if god wanted to create a universe where
everything was clockwork
and if there were any intelligent beings
they were all sort of automatically
wired to worship god from the moment
they were born i guess god could have
done that but it wouldn't have been very
interesting god seems to be interested
in us and giving us that kind of free
will to figure out what we make of all
of this and i think that's a much more
intriguing kind of creation
than something that might have been
simpler
but maybe not so much worth god's time
right
and so with the human genome sequenced
how do you feel about how that data has
been used so far are we are we further
along than you would have hoped by this
stage not as far along
in different areas it may be
one or the other of that i certainly
think in terms of our ability now to be
able to use genomics in research it's
been profound
my own lab studies two diseases one's
type 2 diabetes a common cause
unfortunately of much suffering and the
other a very rare disease progeria which
causes premature aging we couldn't have
done any of that
without the offspring of the human
genome project and the ability to be
able to look at uh dna samples in a
blink of an eye practically and ask
what's there and now to look at that at
a single cell and ask what that cell
what it's doing omics is everywhere
graduate students today in any area of
biology simply cannot imagine how we did
anything useful before we had the genome
project and all of its spin-offs so
research utterly transformed a clinical
practice cancer utterly transformed
cancer is a disease of the genome now
most people in the developed world if
you develop cancer that kind of set of
tools is going to be used to help figure
out which therapy is most likely to help
you and that's a big step forward it's
certainly turning out to be incredibly
valuable in figuring out
all kinds of dilemmas in terms of
diagnoses that people haven't been able
to arrive at for young children where
you know there's something not right now
the really method of choice sequence the
genome see if you can figure out what's
going on there and sometimes save four
or five years of diagnostic odysseys
that lead you almost nowhere
that's all transforming more and more
certainly an infectious disease look
with covit
the spinoff of the genome project to be
able to rapidly sequence viral genomes
has led us to the ability to be able to
track a pandemic in record speed and
discover new variants just as soon as
they start to appear all that's
happening and all of that is incredibly
gratifying has it transformed the
average person's medical care
not really the way i wish it would we
have ways to go particularly when it
comes to prevention that's something
that we really wanted to see that your
individual genome ought to allow a more
precision approach to prevention instead
of one size fits all
this program that we're running called
all of us
in the us which is enrolling a million
people in a prospective longitudinal
study where complete genome sequence and
electronic health records and all kinds
of environmental exposures are being
melded together is going to get us a lot
closer to that and programs like the uk
biobank in britain and programs in
australia that have this same idea we're
going to get there but that takes really
big data sets probably a lot of machine
learning in order to sift through the
complexities of the human body which is
as you said earlier maybe god could have
made this a little simpler but it's what
we got
yeah
uh in the remaining time that we haven't
wanted to turn to the new job that you
mentioned before that you've now taken
on
uh president biden's science advisor
and
with all of the challenges that we face
in the world and all the opportunities
that we have so many of them have a
scientific basis science at their core
from what we're talking now in terms of
medicine personalized medicine alternate
energy issues of climate change global
pandemics of course look nuclear
weapons and war is sort of
back on the table in a shocking way in
recent times
where do you see the role
of someone with your background who
perhaps may have a much closer line to
the ear
of the president of the united states
what role do you see for yourself there
well i didn't expect this role and i'm
right now on my 18th day so i'm still
sorting out exactly how i can best play
this role but we are fortunate in the us
right now to have a president who cares
deeply about science and who is really
interested in getting that kind of
information on every topic hungry to see
the way in which that kind of
science-based evidence-based
decision-making can result in a better
outcome
and so i'm finding myself very much
called upon and it is certainly as you
said it's not just about mice areas that
i'd be more familiar with in biomedicine
it's also about many other aspects where
science is critical um we're having a
meeting day after tomorrow on fusion and
whether there's a advance or a set of
advances that might be possible here uh
to deal with our energy demands and of
course climate crisis uh which
we are way behind on where we should be
in terms of dealing with global warming
and what are the things that can be done
that are going to require international
input so yes my horizons got vastly
enlarged as a result of doing this and
they were already pretty enlarged
serving as the nih director for 12 years
but this takes me into a whole lot of
other areas and i'm kind of glad that i
had that background in physics and
chemistry because it's now becoming
really relevant
and and we scientists
i think as many people watching this
know we are a global community from the
get-go right i mean our colleagues were
constantly talking to people in other
universities in other countries around
the world
and so we have this international
language that we speak from the moment
we walk into the laboratory
to what extent does that
allow you to play
a role that can unify
a world that's fractured i mean i've
heard and and i'm just wondering if it's
true i've heard that science advisors
from many different countries around the
world have a sort of below the radar
meeting meeting set of meetings where
like behind the scenes because you all
know how to talk to each other across
international lines
is that is that true is that part of it
and how do you see the more general idea
of trying to
smooth out these global fractures
it's totally true although i will deny
it if somebody asked me the details
and you would want it to be true yeah
science has this a wonderful tradition
what was it pasteur said science knows
no country it is the torch that
illuminates the world we need that torch
to burn even more brightly right now
with all the fracturing that's happened
in relationships and scientists i think
have invested in those relationships
over the years and we can build on that
because we've learned how to trust each
other and to tell each other the truth
about facts and evidence that's what
science is all about
if if we needed those international
connections in the past we need them
even more now and i do see that as
something that i might be able to help
with the genome project of course was
totally international almost everything
i've worked on that really mattered
whether it was the microbiome or the
cancer genome
have always found its way into an
international collaboration and that's
how the work got done with everybody
agreeing to help each other and to make
the data accessible so that progress
could happen that's what we need to do
even more of now
and uh do you think there needs should
be more scientists who step into public
life
through government or other other means
brian i'm glad you asked i certainly do
i've been greatly benefited and
privileged to serve in these roles with
the genome project with the nih
directorship and now in this role with
the president
it is not a way to make a lot of money
i'll tell you that
but you know ultimately i don't think
that's really what when it comes to the
end of your life you're going to look
back on and say that's what mattered
david brooks has this wonderful
comparison about what it is that people
are trying to achieve is it resume
virtues or is it eulogy virtues
it's the eulogy virtues i think most of
us ultimately wish that we had invested
in public service is a great eulogy
virtue you basically decide to give of
yourself to make the world a better
place and right now science is one of
the strongest ways to get there it's a
little daunting because science is as
you have seen a bit under attack right
now certainly in the united states and
probably in lots of parts of the world
there's such polarization such
divisiveness and politics finds its way
into discussions where it doesn't belong
and science in many ways gets caught up
in that and scientists who are giving
out with valuable evidence-based
information get demonized because people
didn't want to hear it so all the more
reason why i think scientists do need to
be courageous and to be out there in the
public sphere telling the world what the
facts are of the matter in a
interpretable
winsome uh believable way but not hiding
in the lab we've got to be out there
we're part of the solution to the
terrible situation our world seems to be
in
any chance of
francis collins 2028
[Laughter]
okay my prior on that is zero
less stanford is god i love that um
well friends has been a delight speaking
with you and um you know a wonderful
blend of uh big ideas
and ideas that matter to us on a
scientific level on a deeply human level
and
best of luck in the new undertaking and
we can only all hope that you'll have
great impact on shifting policy in a way
that really makes sense for all of
humanity so if it can push us at all in
that direction
god bless you
brian thank you so much it's been a real
privilege to talk with you thank you for
your leadership of this world science
festival over what i guess is now about
13 or 14 years yeah i don't like to
think about how many years it is but i
had different color hair back then so
and more of it that's okay
so so thanks again and look forward to
crossing paths sometime in the future
and to all of you who are watching thank
you so much for joining this world
science festival conversation and you
should subscribe to the world science
festival newsletter the world science
vessel youtube page as well we are going
to be releasing a number of programs in
even the coming weeks just a little
preview we'll have a program on quantum
mechanics a program on longevity a
program on the brain is coming up i
can't even remember all the other ones
that are going to be coming out but
roughly every 2-3 weeks we should now be
providing some really interesting
conversations at the cutting edge of a
variety of sciences so you can look
forward to that so again thank you so
much for joining us i'm looking forward
to seeing you at the next of these world
signs festival conversations
[Music]
you